how many times do you normally have to
watch a film before you decide if you
like it or not I'd say for most you know
instantly upon first viewing nowadays
the vast majority of mainstream films
are specifically designed to appeal to
mass audiences and most of them are
vigorously tested before release to
ensure they'll please the target
demographic to experience mainstream
cinema that takes risks our only sure
bet it seems is the trusted okto
filmmakers that Hollywood has excused
from its soul-crushing machine the
Spielberg's the Scorsese's and
Tarantino's that have time and time
again proven themselves in 1982 Ridley
Scott apparently did not yet occupy that
prestigious group of filmmakers as the
theatrical cut of Blade Runner was
tampered with after disastrous test
screenings an ending narration that
Harrison Ford famously hated was
inserted as well as unused footage from
the shining a clear attempt to explain
the film to audiences Scott wasn't
against the narration idea but wanted
something more along the lines of
classic film noir something
philosophical it's that original cut of
Blade Runner I was first exposed to as a
teen and I remember being very
conflicted by it in fact I'd go as far
as saying I didn't like it eventually I
saw the director's cut and still had
issues with the movie with the release
of the definitive final cut I sat down
to watch Blade Runner expecting to
finally get it but still problems arose
for me I didn't like the sebastian
character I thought he ruined the pacing
and I didn't care for the romance that
blossoms between Deckard and Rachel I
felt the film didn't have enough action
and I found the whole experience
disappointingly Hollow
two years went by and I had decided that
was it I simply didn't get Blade Runner
but with 2049 coming out I found myself
bitching to watch it again this is
something that has never happened to me
why am I constantly drawn to a film that
I don't love why the incessant need to
watch it every few years was
missing something I have no problem
admitting that I absolutely was I bought
the new 4k blu-ray which is the best 4k
transfer I've ever seen for an older
film by the way all these years later
after watching three cuts of the film I
can finally say that I love Blade Runner
it's a flawed masterpiece without a
doubt a film that contains imperfections
as all do but one that's virtually
impossible to stop thinking about every
great hard sci-fi film since 1982 has
the influence of Blade Runner all over
it ghost in the shell' dark City the
matrix strange days Gattaca it's a film
that asks you to soak in so much visual
beauty yet also pay attention to every
word of dialogue one viewing really
isn't enough in my case it was four
viewings one of the best compliments
that a film can get is that its world
feels real in the case of Blade Runner
the misty filthy streets of 2019 Los
Angeles appear so authentic it feels
like you could reach into the screen and
become a part of it few movies
especially futuristic or sci-fi films
have so perfectly crafted a world as
tangible as Blade Runner the internal
mysteries surrounding Deckard and the
famous is he or isn't he questioned
regarding his humanity has fueled film
debates for decades do I think he's a
replicant yeah I kind of do there's
enough hints to suggest it his eyes
changing color like all the replicants
eyes do gaff leaving him the unicorn
origami which was a vision that Deckard
had and told no one about possibly
hinting at implanted memories like the
other replicants there's so much to
glean from this movie while also
appreciating it on a surface level it's
taken four viewings and over a decade
for me to finally love it but I can
confidently say that I do the only real
issue I have with the film is the forced
romance between Deckard and Rachael but
it's the type of flaw that one can
look when everything else was such an
explosion of sensory and auditory
overload I feel that Blade Runner is a
flawed masterpiece if it was perfect
from the get-go Ridley Scott wouldn't be
so tempted to change and alter things
nevertheless due to its cultural impact
and significance
I'm giving Blade Runner and a plus I can
honestly say I never thought I would say
those words because I've spent the large
majority of my life finding this film
rather polarizing but for whatever
reason watching it again recently and
really paying attention to everything
about it I just began to really
appreciate this film I loved it and if
you've never checked it out I definitely
suggest watching the final cut it's the
best cut out of all the ones I've seen
guys look forward to my review of Blade
Runner 2049 and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck the next
[Music]